welcome to episode 117 of film courage
my name is Karen warden my name is David
brainless let's turn our attention to
today's guests sitting beside us here in
studio director producer Linda goldstein
Knowlton Linda's work includes well
writer does the film that you and I love
Karen shipping news the world according
to Sesame Street and her latest
documentary somewhere between on the
site somewhere between movie.com linda
rights my daughter's name is Ruby
Goldstein Knowlton she is five now six
as of the airing of the show when my
husband and I adopted her from China we
had no idea what lay ahead we became a
family in an instant but as I began to
think about Ruby's future I started to
wonder how her coming of age would
differ from mine I began talking to
older girls who had been adopted from
China and brought to the US a decade or
more ago and plunged into a world not
just of identity but what it means to be
who we are my film somewhere between was
born somewhere between exhibits the life
of four young women all adopted from
China their typical American teens with
hobbies and dreams except they all
Harbor lingering questions as to who
they are and where they came from
Linda's been quite busy with the film
both screenings at Hot Docs in Canada
were sold out and the film also won the
hot dogs Sundance Channel audience award
somewhere between is an official
selection for the 2011 Los Angeles Film
Festival please welcome to the film
courage studio miss Linda Goldstein
Knowlton hello hello so happy to be here
yes happy we're thrilled to have here
very excited to speak with you and we've
been extremely touched by the film it's
just beautiful they're hoping thank you
thanks it means a lot thank you thank
you for sharing your story with us let's
begin with your upbringing what were
your building blocks in the formative
years that helped put you in the
position that you're in today okay now
it's for me to like
I'll tell you look at stars well I am
from Chicago grew up in the suburbs of
Chicago highland park and then moved to
San Diego and when I was a teenager so
that so one right there moving in
adolescence prepared me to make this
movie to talk to talk about what happens
in adolescence so that's always been a
question for me in terms of what happens
with people in adolescence it's such a
huge point of identity development for
everybody so that's one thing that's
kind of always been on my mind I grew up
I've two older brothers we grew up in
Chicago had a pretty nice life there and
they influenced me in really wonderful
ways I have a brother who's a scientist
and a brother who is a green businessman
and really really wonderful family now
I'm sorry you said you moved when you
were a teenager so you were kind of
uprooted and had to go to a new school I
did that was culture shock I'm moving
from the suburbs of chicago to san diego
you know when i was when i was in eighth
grade you know Levi's and Adidas were
all the fashion which I guess they are
now to and actually polo shirt but
moving to San Diego where everyone was
blond-haired and blue-eyed and I was not
and they're all wearing their dittos in
there Corky's the core keys are back now
and you know wearing makeup and doing
drugs and that was you know shocking to
me so it was really really big culture
shock so today are you living out a
dream that you had envisioned for
yourself long ago or is this something
totally new that you never expected
you'd be doing I had never an inkling
that I would make films at all growing
up I I wanted to be an English major
when I went to college I mean when I
when iconic got to that point I always
loved reading and storytelling and and
theatre in plays and I was the kid you
know lights were out and I'd have the
flashlight under the blanket and be
reading Nancy Drew or whatever it be
reading and I thought for sure I would
teach or something I didn't exactly know
but something to do with storytelling
and literature and when I went to
college my dad said what are you going
to do with an English major you'll never
know living and you know every dad says
that and then my oldest brother who's a
science
just said what classes are you taking
and I said well I'm taking literature
this and playwriting that and theory
this and and he said you're not taking
any science classes and I said yeah I'm
not because I don't like laughs I'm not
very good at them and and he said
there's got to be one science class that
doesn't have a lab look in the course
catalog so I did and I will give him
credit for this and I the one science
class I could find was introductory to
neuroscience and I had one of those
amazing experiences where the professor
knocked me on my socks and I became a
neuroscience major and I thought I was
going to go to medical school so it was
a yeah so I went down that path for a
while and then realized that I was not
going to go to medical school and and I
took several different detours i worked
in politics i worked for the governor of
Rhode Island and then i moved to
washington DC thinking that i was going
to work in in politics and couldn't find
a job in politics that paid and I
answered an ad in the newspaper for the
American Film Institute to be a
secretary which because they didn't call
them assistance that it was a secretary
so and i worked at AFI and i learned all
about film I immersed myself and I
realized oh this is storytelling this is
I've come full circle very long random
circle but I came back to storytelling
in a totally different medium and it got
me really excited because it was a
collaborative medium and I really i
thought that that was an exciting way to
tell stories and what was the break that
led you to producing well i was working
at AFI and i was working in their kind
of special events department and we were
we would produce big fundraisers
actually to raise money for film
preservation and so I kind of got the
beginning tastes of producing producing
there we did something at the at the
White House we did different things in
LA so that kind of got me involved in
producing and in my course of seeing
what was going on at AFI and what
different people did in jobs I knew that
I didn't want to write and and I really
thought I didn't want to direct and I
thought ah being a creative producer
would be the way to go because it's it
was the right combination of
storytelling and being being involved
creatively but all
so you know not being creative and
problem solving which I which I felt I I
could really add to the to the pie and
all of that so and I thought they did
everything at AFI except make movies
they taught people how to make movies so
eventually I had to move on and so I did
what a lot of people do I I was i did
catering and craft service and was a
runner on a fifty-thousand-dollar
feature I was an assistant at Columbia
Pictures and I did development for a
couple of different producers and and
just work my way up and finally one day
decided I gotta do it myself we're gonna
we're gonna kind of targeting some some
background information about somewhere
between about your personal story here
you know because this is much more than
just a movie this is real babies are
being born in China primarily girls who
are being abandoned let's start with how
did you come to your decision that you
wanted to adopt one of these children
well my husband and I when we decided to
create a family we thought about a lot
of different things and we you know
corny as it may sound we feel like we
are citizens of the world and we were
excited about adopting from China for a
lot of reasons a lot of personal reasons
and the process we knew some people that
had done it and we could talk to about
the whole process and there was
something about the fact that they were
primarily girls that touched my heart
and we just went off and did it we r you
fill out a lot of paperwork it's like
doing your taxes except you involve
Homeland Security and and it was for us
we were very fortunate that it was a it
was a pretty quick process well let's
see if we understand some of the
background of that now in in 1979 was it
China implemented a one child one family
sort of policy and as a result a lot of
the girls were abandoned because they're
not considered is it useful especially
the farming communities that the males
are much more useful to the family
system yeah it's a it's a I am NOT an
expert in China and I mean I I just have
to say that right now so
you know all of it is from my from my
understanding but you know it's a
five-thousand-year-old culture that is
one of the most complex things on earth
and and there's there for me I just feel
like there's no black and white to
anything but there there has been this
one child policy there still is a
one-child policy it's been relaxed in
certain provinces but there is no social
security in China and the especially in
the rural areas where you need sons to
work in the work in the farms or in the
fields or whatever is going on there and
the role communities so a there they
actually work and they're providing for
the families but then when the when the
parents are older the the sons are their
social security basically they take care
of them in an old age and the daughters
get married and move off and all of that
so there is this very practical issue
that they have to contend with and I
understand what some of these children
that sometimes they're just simply left
by a roadside or with a note pinned to
them is that right yeah I mean I feel
that the girls that have found
themselves and boys to them that have
found themselves adopted or at the
orphanages in China my personal feeling
is that their birth families cared very
very much about them and put them in a
place where they would be found very
quickly and so they would put them near
a flower market or a fish market or in a
train station and in some cases near an
orphanage not everyone knows where all
the orphanages are in China but they
would they would put them there and it
you know probably in dark and darkness
um and but they would put them in a
place where they would be found because
they really wanted their their
children's to their children to have a
better life let's go back quickly to the
screening process now you said it was a
lot like doing your taxes but with
Homeland Security involved like what
kind of questions were you being asked
and
to adopt a child you know some very
basic things family background and and
what you do for a living and income
doctor you know you have to get a
medical medical records and all that but
you have to I think it's like adoption
anywhere that you have to prove that
you're not a criminal things like that
on the state level and on the national
level and then there are so that's from
the US side and then from the China side
there are really good questions how are
you going to raise this child
philosophically with a religion you know
just your philosophy about raising
children and all of that so it to me
there was nothing it was a lot of
paperwork but there was to me there was
nothing outrageous about it so now you
say in the beginning of the film that
you shot this over three years and it
began with your own journey when you
adopted your daughter who at the time
was 10 months old at what point do you
go from being in that moment to saying
you know what I want to roll cameras is
a bigger story here when I i was in
post-production on the world according
to Sesame Street my my prior documentary
that i did with Lynda Hawkins Costigan
and I knew in my husband I were doing
the in all of his paperwork for the
adoption and I just knew that these two
very complex ideas of China and family
and they were going to collide and I
thought there's good there's going to be
a film here there's going to be
something to explore and at first I
thought that I would do a film trying to
explore the birth families side of
things and I realized that that to two
things one is that that I wouldn't
really be able to have access to them
even if I had a Chinese partner but much
more importantly that's not my film to
make that's a Chinese filmmakers film to
make its that that type of film to me is
not shouldn't come from an outsider that
needs to come from within if anyone
wants to explore those questions and
about a year later we had a reunion of
our adoption group there were ten of the
14 families got together in the bay area
and it was the first time we saw most of
them and it was so exciting to see these
girls and running around
happy and giggling and you know just
really healthy and doing terrifically
and and to see the parents last time we
saw them we were all you know pay steven
exhausted at four o'clock in the morning
with our children in a hotel you know la
biet in china so it was great to
reconnect with everybody and see
everybody thriving basically and we were
driving home my husband and my daughter
and I and I thought oh I know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do seven up I'm going
to do the 7up series with these girls
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna call
it ate up because eight is lucky in
China and I have the good fortune
fortune to know Michael Apted so i
called him up I said Michael I would
like to rip you up entirely is that okay
and he was very lovely and generous and
he said sure absolutely it's a great
idea but he gave me a really valuable
piece of advice which was he reminded me
that 7up started as a one-off and so he
said why don't you step back and really
think about what do you want to explore
with this film and if you follow the
girls every eight years icing on the
cake but really stop and think about
where what's the central idea you want
to look at and it was the you know is
the best advice I got that's what I did
now your personal story book ends this
film how was it for you and your husband
to allow the cameras into your life at
some point did you feel that it was too
much not enough i was i actually had no
intention of ever being in the film so
the fact that I'm in the book ends and
at the end in a bathing suit that was
that was never in the cards so i feel
like i have truly suffered from my art
but i got some feedback from some very
smart filmmakers and showed them some
some cutscenes and some cut pieces and
that i wasn't it that we didn't have
these book ends and they all said why
aren't you in the movie I said yeah
because this is from the girls points of
view to me the most important thing
about this film is that it's from the
girls points of view and that I didn't
want to impose anything and they said to
me but you have to give context you know
you are an adoptive mom and a filmmaker
and it's it'll actually be kind of
strange in a way to
not have that context of where you're
coming from you're not just an observer
in this situation this is personal and
they're very smart and I I thought it
was really valid really really valid so
in the beginning that's actually just
our home movies just shot on a little
you know Oh movie HD camera and not even
HD am I saying mini DV camera and and at
the end like I said I knew that I wanted
to show my daughter at a certain age and
we're at the beach and what am I gonna
do in a bathing suit wow I'm really glad
you made the decision cuz you know
seeing seeing that at you know the book
ends there it really just draws you into
the story really brings in so I'm really
glad that you listen to these wise
filmmakers that they gave you that
advice it really just makes it that much
more beautiful than experiencing story
you know we mentioned your daughter when
do you plan on showing your daughter
this film because you made it for your
daughter I did I made it for Ruby she
has seen the parts that she's in
actually so she says she's seen the
bookends but the rest of it I really
probably when she's 13 or 14 is my guess
okay I feel like it's it's it's um the
girls start out 13 and 14 in the film
and I feel like what emotionally what
they're going through is is you know
right on for that age range and I just
feel like I just it's pg-13 we have a
cat that we adopted from a shelter and
they made up her age and made her
actually younger than she is now I
understand that that's something that
they do with these children to kind of
get them adopted they may be change
their ages to make them younger is that
right well I know that that was the case
with them or we believe that's the case
with phong because she was adopted at an
older age and in terms of the when when
children are adopted as babies they
don't know their exact birthday but I
been there when they're infants that
they don't that they're not really
switching their ages it's just much more
of trying to guess
what their birth date is another thing i
found interesting is in the film it
shows some of the girls on a panel i
believe it's in barcelona somewhere and
someone stood up and they said how do
you cope with the word abandoned and
they had different reactions to it and
one of them said you know it drove me to
be a perfectionist and compensate for
feeling left behind is that a common
theme with these girls because they all
seem so together and mature for their
age yeah they're very articulate I'm
certainly not that articulate when I was
when I was a teenager what was important
to me in the film was to show a real
range of experience so for Jenna that
was her experience that she had that
inkling in the back of her mind all the
time and it did drive her to be a
perfectionist and with the other girls
they have different drives and different
motivations and and that's what that was
important for me to show that there's no
one way to have this experience and it's
good it affects everyone very
differently so some people dwell on it
some people don't some people it'll it
might come up for them at an older age
or it might not even come up at all and
it'll they'll be thinking about their
identity in very different ways more
culturally or I don't even know in
various different ways maybe when
they're older they'll think more about
the gender part of it you know from I
asked all the girls in the beginning you
know how do you feel about being a girl
does it affect you at all being a young
woman knowing that you have the life you
have because of your gender and I really
dated myself because they all looked at
me like I was a Martian like yeah I'm a
girl I can do whatever I want I can you
know so it was no and so maybe we've
come a long way and it won't affect them
and maybe that's just something that
hits you in your 20s not sure Linda you
know let's talk a little bit about the
logistics and the challenge of here you
are you're raising your adopted daughter
and at the same time you're directing
and producing this film how how are you
doing now how are you balancing these
two worlds a very good question I don't
know ask the people around me um it was
it was really it was really hard it was
uh it was my first film
as a parent so juggling all of these new
ideas of being a parent and and being a
filmmaker it was it's it was trial by
fire and it was really complicated and
also very satisfying and gratifying and
thank goodness for skype and ichat
because that made it all really really
possible i went to china for 16 days and
if it hadn't been for skype I don't know
what I would have done but the the time
difference actually was really really
helpful so when I was getting ready in
the morning ruby was having dinner and
vice versa so we had actually had a lot
of we actually had a lot of skype time
which was nice but that you know that
irony never escaped me that I was away
from my daughter in order to make this
film for my daughter but so that was
that was tricky and but it all worked
thank you to my incredible husband who
made that hugely possible and and and
all the people are our family in our
lives that that that helped make it
possible ruby is very well-loved and and
everyone just rose to the occasion it
was really it was great where did you
turn for financing and what challenges
did you face if you go to somewhere
between movie com or our Facebook page
you can make a tax-deductible donation
to help us pay for our movie that we're
still paying for I turn to I'm serious
but I turn to everyone literally
strangers but also people who have been
fans of my films some incredible angel
contributors and grassroots I sent out
grassroots emails several times and you
know people have contributed anywhere
from twenty-five dollars too many
thousands of dollars because
logistically it was it's an expensive
film the girls live all over the country
I had to travel to see them a lot that
two girls went to China so those are two
trips to China two girls went to Europe
two trips to Europe it was a it's a it's
an expensive proposition so but people
really rose to the occasion for that too
so it's it's so it's a work in progress
so we're can progress it's what was your
pitch letter like I'm always wondering
how strong do you come on
when asking for money and how much how
many times do you repeat if you don't
hear from someone that you know ah come
on pretty strong I probably follow
through you know two or three times
there's a certain point where you know
that you've sure their people are not
interested in you you've out you know
you don't let the door hit you on the
way out and and actually one of my
closest friends said to me if you start
another film without having your full
funding again I will do an intervention
and I've told that to a few people on
there like yes we will be there and
actually my therapist said I will be
there so so it's um that's probably the
hardest part of the whole shrinking of
the movie to be honest with you like
crowdfunding yeah you're never you're
never sure how many times to kind of go
back to that well and also how
persistent to be where you may turn
someone off in the meantime absolutely
in terms of the size and the scope of
this production team working on this
movie how would how would the the team
you know the team members you have on
this one how would that compared to a
film like Whale Rider a narrative
feature can you talk about the
differences for those sure well it's
funny that you mentioned whale rider
because that was also filmmaking family
but it was in you know probably close to
a hundred people and my documentary
family is for people that's myself it's
my cinematographer sound person and
editor and actually my my primary
cinematographer and sound mixer
I call them my work husband's so Nelson
human been poz neck and I've traveled
around the world with them I can't even
think 15 times something they worked on
the world according to Sesame Street
they worked on this also and it's a very
it's a very tight wonderful familial
team and I don't know how we do without
them actually so when you're traveling
as you mentioned couple trips to Europe
you know several trips to China is
redditor going as well it is is it just
this is just the sound guy in the
cinematographer and you that are
traveling so the three of you no matter
so every time we see where wherever the
shot is it's always the three of you
together it's the three of us and quite
off and so in those cases I'm the Sherpa
I'm the agent it's really not glamorous
it's fantastic and I'm fortunate to do
what I do there's nothing glamorous
about it so there's a I think it's
actually on our Facebook page is a
picture of me where I'm I have the
sticks in a backpack I have you know my
bag I have the sound guys bag I've like
batteries I'm like literally like I'm a
tree you know like a hat tree you know
carrying all the equipment and then our
editor was here in LA Katie Flint
although she's now moved to New York and
so you know bless her heart I'd come
home with these hard drives of material
and she was this is her first feature
length film that she edited herself and
I'm so impressed and proud of her and
again couldn't have made this movie
without her and she had great
perspective and just great skill and
pulling a lot of story together because
it's for girls everyone has a lot going
on it's a lot to pull together so she
really did it I think she constructed
scenes be really beautifully what was
the process like in you finding these
four girls how did you know that these
were the right ones when you see the
movie like oh yeah how could it be
anybody else better I found them with
the help of two wonderful organizations
once called families with children from
China and they have chapters all across
North America in California there's
probably four or five chapters just in
California
and through that organization they've
been very supportive and Peggy Scott in
Northern California help me and
introduced me to Fong so that's hi Matt
Fong and then there's another
organization called Chinese adopted
links and through that organization
through a young woman named Jennifer
juice stoic who started this
organization by Chinese adoptees for
Chinese adoptees she introduced me to
haley anna and Jenna what was it like
getting the families involved I mean how
did you navigate through all that well
the families were just very kind and
supportive and lovely and you know just
kept inviting us back into their homes
and making us lunch and because it was
really quite lovely but I think the idea
that because I'm an adaptive mom and I
could talk them through the idea of
respect and Trust and that I would that
I feel for their daughters that it's the
same that I feel from my own daughter I
think that created a real sense of trust
and being comfortable all of us with
each other because like I said we were
in their homes a lot and we traveled
with them a lot and and they were really
really terrific and I and I think one
thing that happened was both the girls
and their parents and specifically about
the girls you know they said I mean they
we felt we'd built a rapport we felt
comfortable with each other but they a
couple of them said to me you know i
wish i had this movie to see when i was
starting to be a teenager and they
because i said to them you know what
you're doing here is a gift to all the
kids coming up and i think they really
could they could really feel it and they
really appreciated it and so they liked
having a voice but i think too it's not
just for people who are adopted i think
it's for people to that grew up maybe
without a parent that they never knew
about that was sort of always this
idealized parent that was invisible and
and you
lose a sense of who you are and you kind
of always are looking for that piece and
always trying to do something to kind of
compensate for that so I think a lot of
people can relate to this even if it's
not just coming from an adoptive family
I know you don't call them subjects I
know they're they're part of your new
family now when you sit down with these
girls that you're interviewing how do
you know the the soundbite that you're
going for me what are you looking for
and that take you know the great thing
about documentary the great thing and
the fear of documentary is the unknown
so you know I have my lists of questions
and and where we're going to go where I
want to go and then they they take me
down a different path which is terrific
and so sometimes I'll see oh we're going
down this new path that I didn't expect
and that's where we're going and then
sometimes I mean I have a notebook still
where I i wrote art yeah I wrote in the
notebook this is going to be this is
going to be the last line of the movie
and I was I was pretty close actually so
sometimes you just hear it sometimes you
know it and then there's the the crazy
part which is there's that incredible
sound bite that beautiful moment that uh
you just live for it and that doesn't
make it in the movie but it'll go on the
DVD extras so let you know they're just
theirs it's the only finite amount of
time to tell a story and how much how
much prep work are you doing you know
behind the scenes ahead of time let me
start there then I have a follow-up
question I guess so for for prep I mean
everything involved in prep is
everything from plane tickets to visas
to getting permission from the schools
from you know talking to parents to I
mean any number of just regular old
logistics actually hailey hailey took a
picture of the word logistics in England
Ajit she posted it on Facebook and she
said this is Miss Linda's favorite word
so there's just a lot of logistics you
have to post notices that you're you're
filming you have to make sure you get
people's permission and then how much of
the story are you crafting you know are
you coming in with any sort of things
that you're writing down some any story
elements saying like I have to get this
or I'm going to sort of manipulate this
craft this in a certain way because I
need this for for the narrative of this
film from day one the intention of this
film was to give the girls a voice and
from for the for the stories to be from
their points of view so I went in to
this film not wanting to say anything I
wanted to give them a platform and and
in choosing the girls the subjects I
chose them because they were from very
different parts of the United States I
really wanted to show you know an
example of America through these girls
from living in big cities to smaller
towns to you know diverse areas to less
diverse areas but I also wanted to show
I found these different girls who have
certain commonalities but because they
were born in China or just because their
adolescent girls but I also wanted to
show these girls because they each had a
different way of expressing their
experience their having different
experiences and they were expressing
them in different ways so that's what I
wanted and that's what led me that's
what helped craft the story when you sit
down with them for these interviews what
is like the shortest interview would
like it what is the shortest in the
longest interview when you just sit down
and you're just rolling camera you know
and you finally see something you say
okay now i know we have what we have i'm
just curious on both ends of the
spectrum i mean do you get do you
capture that moment in 15 minutes art
yet well usually it you know takes half
an hour to set up the lighting so you're
really good to make sure that your
unless you're really on the fly and
you're just you know some place you're
in a restaurant you're somewhere you're
just going like you know grab a quick
question or two so there's that there's
there's no kind of those kinds of
moments you're in the moment you're
someplace you're it's it's not verte but
you're in the verities but then if I'm
setting up for an interview we've you
know we've lit and all of that I would
say the shortest is probably half an
hour and the longest is probably an hour
ish so you usually falling within those
those parameters yeah sometimes you know
there's bathroom breaks we get up go a
little longer but you know and also kind
of depending you know if when we are on
location when we were in Europe or in
China
and I knew that we weren't going to
emotionally be in this moment again and
in this physical space sometimes we you
know we'd go a little bit longer just to
make sure we really covered everything
and within these three years how many
hours of footage did you end up with I
you know I've locked that number out of
my mind you know few hundred several
hundred so yeah it was it just
overwhelming to sit through it and just
way to sit down with the editor you'll
have to ask Katie okay I'm trying to
think of the direction so I imagine when
you start this project I imagine you sit
down with these girls and you sort of
share your vision and you saw that you
know and I think you mentioned you kind
of said this isn't just for my daughter
anyone's this is this is going to be
something that's going to be a project
for many people that are in your same
kind of shoes I imagine it starts with a
lot of dialogue in the beginning I can
also see it as it moves on as we head
toward year three that you probably just
come in and maybe just set up the
cameras and the dialogue you know you
don't need as much conversation ease
much direction it with that was that was
that the case for the for this film that
is the case as the couple years went on
I would come to them I was you know is
in constant contact with them by text or
Facebook because they don't email
because they're young so you know I
would then come in for certain for
certain moments knowing that there was
going to be you know Fung's art show or
you know there were different there were
different moments that we came there to
capture so that would be the primary
purpose of the of the shoot and then you
know you need to still get some of that
stuff that might be a voiceover or that
might set up the situation so you still
always had to have a little there would
always be an interview in everett with
every trip but much fewer at the end
then there were at the beginning and in
those instances where you are sitting
across from them what are you saying to
them what kind what kind of direction
are you giving them well and I never
really gave them direction I just ask
them questions you know so but it would
be about you know in the beginning it
was the most broad you know
tell me about school friends this your
activities you know activities led in a
certain direction so jenos on crew she
was the Cox'n of the crew and so we went
off in the crew direction for a while
and and where that went so it was really
everything was predicated we did the big
broad net of questions kind of
everything about their lives and then as
we started following them we started we
you know you put out a lot of fishing
lines basically and you see which ones
are going to be the most fruitful and
then you follow those lines and if you
find that one of the girls was maybe
censoring herself a little bit how did
you make her feel more comfortable can't
tell you my tricks no you know there
would be times where it was just it's
just talking it's just it's just um
building our it's building a rapport and
and and talking about the emotion and
then there'd be some there's to be some
times that I would push a little deeper
and then there were some times that I
wouldn't because I felt that not just to
be respectful but I also i felt like if
someone actually came out and said you
know what I don't want to answer that
question that's private I think by
actually saying that that's in a very
empowering thing for girls to hear and
in this case no one actually really came
out and said that but I gave them that
opportunity i said if there's something
that you don't want to answer don't
answer it but let me know because i
think that you know by the very nature
of when my daughter when these girls
walk outside with their families their
history their private story is public
and so people feel that they can then
talk to them about anything and ask them
anything and and maybe out of good
nature but there's not a really great
language to talk about adoption and i
think that some people aren't I don't
think you need to treat it with kid
gloves but i think that there's a
sensitivity that people don't have
partially because it hasn't been
normalized with a lot of language so i
think that for the girls sometimes
people just expect them to answer every
question
and uh and so I really wanted to give
them the opportunity to empower
themselves and say you know what that's
my story I don't talk about it sort of
build up a sense of boundary absolutely
yeah absolutely absolutely not that
there's anything to be ashamed of but
you know what I'll feel like talking
about it yeah it's their life it's their
story and and they're protective of it
understood yeah you know and here in the
early going the film has connected with
audiences you know you've gotten into
hot docs you're currently at the LA Film
Festival so you you're receiving
recognition from some of the largest
most prestigious outlets that you
possibly could how has the heat all
right you know or how much how much heat
sort of comes from being involved in
these prestigious festivals well it's
you know it's we're in our own bubble
making this film we feel really really
good about it and hope that other people
feel the same way so when we got into
hot docs it was I mean a huge honor it's
an incredible incredible festival so we
were so proud to be there and then we
won the Audience Award and we you know
just knocked our socks off so that was
that was really really incredible that
the audience is connected in that way
and also sitting in you know sitting in
the theater and feeling no it's that
communal experience watching a movie
with an audience and when they laugh and
when it's dead silent except for
sniffles you know you feel it in the
room and that was really it was was very
exciting and then to get into the Los
Angeles Film Festival which is awesome
and it has been just a great experience
being a part of this festival it's nice
it's getting the attention and so now
hopefully you know we'll find ways to
get it out into the into the broader
audiences that now it into the world
that you know so to participate in
festivals and then to get a broader
distribution what would have happened
had you not gotten into these festivals
what would your strategy have been bite
your tongue you know what I just would
have the it's the persistence you know
just would have kept applying to
festivals and festivals and and you know
it is this new world of distribution
that I
you know barely understand you know
shifting shifting big gears but there's
a lot of really interesting distribution
strategies going on now with VOD and
different types of DVD situations and
and streaming and all of that that I you
know I'm trying to wrap my head around
so there are a lot of exciting
opportunities that aren't just
straightforward distribution which of
course I would like to but it just would
be exploring all different ways of
getting the film out and one thing
that's been really fun I'm loving
Facebook is you know hearing from people
all over the country and from around the
world saying when can I see it when are
you coming to Australia when are you
coming to the UK when you come to Spain
when you come in Raleigh North Carolina
we want to screening we want to
screening we want a screening so that
you know that's exciting sounds like you
need to empower that audience is what it
sounds like home definitely go to the
Facebook page and like us make it
honestly makes a difference yeah it all
makes it you should consider maybe
eventful or something along those lines
where people can literally you know say
I want to see the screening and you know
give them the tools get the tools to get
behind it and screen it but it does as a
sound like you you did have a festival
strategy it sounds like you know that
that you you initially targeted the
higher caliber festival so it was that
was that part of the plan to go after
hot dogs go outlet after LA Film
Festival and then if need be then sort
of scale down to maybe a smaller scale
film festival absolutely I mean I've had
really great fortune of going to some
top caliber film festivals with my films
so so that's I just you know followed in
the same follow the same strategy filed
the same path and and felt strongly and
and that we would that we would be
received well so happily was started
with hot docs for our world premiere in
LA for our US premiere and we sold out
last night so if you want to come buy
your tickets now for 30 on wednesday and
7 30 on tuesday and that's actually
already gone rush so you'll have to get
congratulations thank you wonderful yeah
we saw this crowd of people around you
yesterday so you've mentioned that it
really wanted to give these girls of
voice what's the message you want to
leave people with there's several
messages most importantly there's no one
way to have this experience that
whatever you as an adoptee you as a
person are experiencing that's a valid
experience and there's no right way or
wrong way there's nothing you're
supposed to do there's nothing you're
supposed to feel that that it's really
important that too that your feelings
are fair and true and that's the way and
that's the way to go with it and you
know I hope that there are some people
out there who watch the movie and say oh
wow I feel that same way and you know I
didn't feel comfortable talking to
someone about it and now I can see that
I'm not alone in that feeling that
someone else is having that same
experience with that same feeling and
you know it's been you touched on this
before that this is not just for adopted
people or top two people from China I
mean people have come up to me after
screenings and saying I'm not adopted
but I related in this way and for any
number of any number of reasons and it's
it's been really interesting you know
Asian Americans coming up and saying I
grew up in small town someplace and I
related I'm not adopted but this is how
I related and then people of all you
know of all different backgrounds saying
I relate to this way because it's the
most universal thing is developing your
identity and and where you where you fit
in yourself and where you fit in your
world and this is also where you fit in
your family sure no it's beautifully put
and I think it it does help people
articulate those feelings that maybe
they didn't even know they were there
and then they they see them out there
with these girls stories and really feel
a sense of connection so the girls have
seen the film yes they have all four
girls and their families I flew out to
each of their their homes and showed
them the film I mean I just couldn't
imagine putting it in the public without
showing them first I mean there's they
were so generous all of them the girls
and their families with their with their
lives so I just I needed to show it to
them for
and they were all you know it's a little
weird seeing yourself um but they were
all very proud to participate and they
were all they all they liked it great
we've been speaking with director
producer Linda goldstein Milton go see
her movie and I can also keep track
otherwise by visiting somewhere between
movie calm and also go to the Facebook
page and like it and there is a donate
button on the website tax deductible
okay thanks inaudible Thank You Linda
thank you thank you for spending time
here in studio with us you know it it is
a beautiful story and it's just great to
see you know a loving mother you know
make this well-crafted just well
produced film for her daughter this is
just beautiful thank you so much it's
been great talking with you both and
until next Sunday have a great week